dis là c'est bon j'ai vu ça ok c'est
super ça voilà voilà tpr souper on va
voir un autre à long terme que passer
devant ça va être superbe dans le tram
qui va arriver devant qui va le cacher
et prévoit l'accueil ou pas ce bateau de
toute crise historique face aux
clarisses le plus beau ouais ok on y va
on va sûrement une approbation les
arbres ok et puis hier alors fait de jeu
des zooms comme tu veux il ya un arbre
que juste derrière tu vois moi j'ai dû
moi un petit peu tu as souvent un peu a
pas senti voilà et cas pour le matou
bloc baisse passant de bâtir de passer
un peu derrière eux un soufflé
malheureusement que et oliva dispute ok
la pression prendre envers les armes
après la fin où il passe wickenheiser
j2ee laissez-passer laisser sortir on
continue encore et le vent ballack goku
golan êtes en hockey et on continue sur
les armes vendues et on continue comme
ça c'est un bon plan ou pas ça chez
l'oncle l'hélico entier je veux qu'on
leur fasse tous et bon ok il a aucun
fondement aux candidats et on passe
devant et on suit derrière les arbres et
oui pas sa glace
elle lui donne oui lors qu'ils abattent
auquel fantastique
ils ont entassé attention soit pas trop
génial génial génial fantastique mais
pas souvent de résine au hockey like
this is your face au voisin ait choisi
dès l'âge de 6 ans
ok